let me tell you a story
so a friend of mine and i we went for a
run in central park
the road runners organization uh on the
weekends they host
races and it's very common at the end of
the race they'll have a sponsor who will
give away
something apples or bagels or something
and on
this particular day when we got to the
end of the run there were
some free bagels and they had picnic
tables set up
and on one side was a group of
volunteers on the table were boxes of
bagels
and on the other side was a long line of
runners
waiting to get their free bagel so i
said to my friend let's let's get a
bagel
and he looked at me and said ah that
line's too long
and i said free bagel
and he said i don't want to wait in line
and i was like free bagel
and he says nah let's it's too long and
that's when i realized
that there's two ways to see the world
some people
see the thing that they want and some
people see the thing
that prevents them from getting the
thing that they want
i could only see the bagels he could
only see the line
and so i walked up to the line
i leaned in between two people
put my hand in the box and pulled out
two bagels
and no one got mad at me because the
rule is you can go after whatever you
want
you just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want
now i had to sacrifice choice i didn't
get to choose which bagel i got i got
whatever i pulled out
but i didn't have to wait in line so the
point is is you don't have to wait in
line
you don't have to do it the way
everybody else has done it you can do it
your way
you can break the rules you just can't
get in the way of somebody else
getting what they want that's rule
number one define for us
an infinite game so in
the mid 1980s a theologian named james
carsey
wrote this little book called finite and
infinite games in which he defines these
two kinds of games
finite games which have known players
fixed rules
and agreed upon objectives football
right there's always a beginning a
middle and an end
and the the objective is to win the game
and then there's infinite games infinite
games are defined as
known and unknown players you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are
the rules are changeable you can play
however you want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
um what i find so fascinating about this
idea when i first learned about it
is we are players in multiple infinite
games
every day of our lives there's no such
thing as being the winner in your
marriage you know
there's no such thing as winning global
politics and there's definitely no such
thing as winning business
business is an infinite game and yet
when we listen to the language
of too many leaders they talk about
being number one
being the best and beating their
competition based on what
there's no agreed upon objectives
there's no agreed upon time frames and
so what ends up happening is you have
people building organizations and
leading with a finite mindset
playing to win in a game where there's
no such thing as winning
and when we play with a finite mindset
in an infinite game
there's a few very predictable and
consistent outcomes
amongst which include the decline of
trust
the decline of cooperation the decline
of innovation
all of which contribute to the eventual
demise of the organization itself
um and so what i wrote about is is is
what it means to lead with an infinite
mindset because we teach leadership
as if it were a finite game um you know
people start business with the goal of
winning or being number one
and that's a problem um because that's
impossible
um so what i wrote about in the infinite
game is is leading with an infinite
mindset there are two
currencies in the infinite game will and
resources
resources is money you need money to
stay in the game but you need the will
of the people as well
and the problem is is that when we
organize to win that means the score
is more important than the inspiration
and motivation than people have to
to give their blood sweat and tears and
when we prioritize resources before will
that's a problem
i've never met a ceo that doesn't
believe their people are important
the problem is where on the priority
list you know
we've been to any number of uh
presentations
where they put their priorities on the
wall you know number one growth number
two
shareholder value number three our
customer number four our employees there
it is see i do care about our people
and the reality is as social animals we
want to
work for and we're willing to give our
blood sweat and tears to leaders who
understand that the balance of those two
essential
currencies the balance of those two
things is will
has to come before resources and that
doesn't mean
90 10 when i talk about putting people
before profit you know people freak out
which is ridiculous
you need fuel for the car to go money is
fuel for the organization
of course even if there's a leaning it's
5149 there has to be a slight leaning
towards
people because there will always be
decisions that a company has to make
in which those two cannot both be
supplied and one will have to be
sacrificed the question the question is
which will you always prioritize
um let me give you a hypothetical
example to make my point
two ceos the first ceo says our number
one priority is growth
and of course our people are important
because if we take care of our people we
will meet and exceed our financial goals
second ceo says our number one priority
is our people
and if we take care of our people we
will always meet and exceed our
financial goals
which one would you rather work for i
don't know i mean it's obvious
right it's obvious so this is what it
means to prioritize will of resources it
has
of course of course money matters
but the people matter more success is an
elusive thing right
um what is it and i think it's very
interesting
that if most people can't define success
well it means you made x amount of
dollars
or but if you make x amount of dollars
but you spend more
are you successful or well it means you
come home happy every day
okay how do you know when you're happy
you know uh
so i think success is a funny thing
which is we all seem to pursue it
but we don't know how to measure it or
actually how to define it
so how do you pursue something that you
can't measure fascinating
so when people say to me how do you
measure success the question we all have
to ask ourselves am i successful
i don't know i mean i had a good year
last year
uh and what does that mean does that
mean i made a lot of money does that
mean i was really happy
oh i'll let you decide right right um
maybe neither maybe both
um i had a good year last year but am i
successful
and the answer is no i don't feel i am
because
i'm trying to build a world that doesn't
exist yet i'm trying to build a world
in which 90 of people go home at the end
of the day feeling fulfilled by the work
that they do
so i definitely took a step a big step
forward towards that goal but i'm still
so far away
so somebody said to me then how do you
know if you're successful and the answer
is
if it can go by itself and so what is
more interesting to me
as a measurement of success is not the
the the markers per se
it's not the the financial goal or the
the size of the house that you want to
buy those are nice things go for it
those are
but those are not measurements of
success those are just nice things to
collect along the way
um for me it's momentum i want to
measure momentum which is
you know when when something is moving
and you start to see it lose momentum
you're like oh
give it a push because if you don't give
it push it's going to stop and an object
in stasis is much harder to get going it
requires a lot more energy
to get something started than it does to
keep it going right and so
if you don't let it stop and you can
keep it going it's this you know it
still might slow down down there but you
can get it going again much easier
and for me the opportunity is to get the
ball rolling faster and faster and
faster and faster and faster and bigger
and bigger and bigger it's like a
snowball
and my responsibility is because it's
not rolling downhill yet it's not on
automatic yet
i need to still keep it going to find
that critical mass where it can go
and at the point it can go by itself
without me then i will find something
else to do
and that may not happen in my lifetime i
think we must all stop measuring
promotions salaries and these things but
rather measure the momentum of your
career
does my career have momentum can i see
it moving in the right direction can i
see it gathering
moss you know can i see that it's easy
becoming easier for me
to keep the momentum it's becoming
easier for me to grow
the size of this thing it's it's
requiring less effort that's the thing
we need to measure
that's the thing that we need to be
cognizant of which is the momentum of
our careers not just
the markers that we think define our
success the thinking of milton friedman
the
the 1970s economist has really dominated
sort of business theory today he
theorized that the responsibility of
business this is his definition the
responsibility
of business is to maximize profit within
the bounds of the law
right what about ethics you know
like a a pharmaceutical company that
raises the price on essential drug
200 300 500 800
it's not illegal it is unethical right
it makes us uncomfortable and yet the
law
is not broken that's not a good enough
standard to run a business
um and it was his thinking that gave
rise to the
the theory of shareholder supremacy
which was a theory proposed in the late
1970s where we prioritize
the once needs and desires of a
shareholder over
the needs of the customer or the
employee which is like a coach
who's trying to build a great team by
doing what the fans want
versus what the players need right
that's basically shareholder supremacy
and as i said it was just a theory
proposed in late 1970 that was
popularized
during the boom years of the 80s and 90s
mass layoffs where we use the
livelihoods of human beings
to meet arbitrary projections on an
annualized basis at the end of the year
did not exist did not exist as a
standard business practice prior to the
1980s
did not exist it was popularized during
during the 80s and 90s
the dismantling of glass-steagall which
was an act passed after the great
depression
to prevent another great depression from
happening and by the way was
extremely effective between the
dismantling of the glass-steagall in the
80s and 90s
and the great depression there were a
total of zero stock market crashes
since then dismantling all in the name
of corporate profit
we've had three we had uh the dot-com
boom black monday in 2008.
in other words when we play simply with
a finite mindset
we actually do long-term damage to our
own system that's supposed to benefit
uh all of us and and i find that
upsetting
um we've seen the rise of of of milton's
uh friedman's thinking rather and like i
said
his theories dominate business today and
we feel it
not only have we had those those stock
market crashes
but anybody who goes to work today
there's a general feeling of unease
you know especially if you work for a
company that embraces
annual or even quarterly layoffs to meet
arbitrary projections
keep in mind a lot of the companies that
employ
mass layoffs are profitable just not as
profitable as they would like it's not
like they're losing money and they had
to do this
to save the sinking ship that's
something completely different
these are highly profitable companies
that missed a projection
and so they laid people off so they
could meet that projection
there's something fundamentally wrong
with that and we know it because we
feel it at work we see this decline of
trust we are not loyal to our companies
anymore
why would we be they're not loyal to us
and leaders set the tone
so when companies are loyal to us we
will give loyalty back to them
when they're not loyal to us why would
we be loyal to them
i'm tired of of ceos telling me
that you know millennials these days
don't stick around very long
well why would they if you don't offer
them any kind of loyalty
uh back and it's not for the people to
prove to you that they're loyal it's the
other way around
discovering your why is just the
beginning in order to enjoy
all the benefits of having a clearly
articulated why
you'll need to have the courage and
discipline to use it
like thomas edison said vision with that
execution
is hallucination there is an ideal order
for implementing your why
though sometimes reality does get in the
way and it all starts with you
our natural tendency is to start with
the tangible
we define our value by what we do so it
takes practice to start with why
like riding a bicycle at first we're
unsure unsteady
we're in our heads thinking about all
the things we need to do pedal fast keep
enough speed so we don't fall over
we have to really concentrate we may
even fall over even scrape our knees
but we get back on the bike and try
again and eventually
it becomes natural starting with why is
no different
at first it feels awkward it may not
even work
but with practice it will become so
natural that you won't even be able to
imagine a time when you couldn't
do it just like riding a bicycle
in time your why will act as a filter
for many of the decisions and choices
you make
it becomes a tool to help you find a job
or seize an opportunity
in which you're more likely to succeed
it removes a lot of the guessing
here's a metaphor to show you what i
mean it's called
the salary test we're constantly asking
people for their advice on what to do or
how to do it
it's like going to a dinner party and
somebody says do you know what you need
you need m ms we've done so well with m
m's you've got to use m ms
somebody else says to us rice milk in
this economy you have to use rice milk
someone else says to us kit kats you
have to use kitkats
and somebody else says to you it's all
about celery
we go to the supermarket with all this
good advice from all these smart people
with brilliant case studies
and we buy everything we buy kit kats
and m ms celery and rice milk
there's a lot of time we spend at the
supermarket and a lot of money we spend
at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout lane
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands
and no one can see what we believe
because we bought everything
but let's imagine we know our why let's
imagine our why is to always be healthy
and only do things that protect the
health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people
this time we only buy celery and we only
buy rice milk they're the only two that
makes sense
we spend less time and less money at the
supermarket and when we're standing
there in line with only celery and only
rice milk
now people can see what we believe
somebody walking past can say hey i can
see that you're healthy so am i
you just attracted an opportunity or a
referral or a friend
simply by saying and doing the things
that you believe and the best part
is it's scalable as soon as i said the
why
you knew exactly which products we were
going to buy
this means the more you can articulate
your why the more
others will know what you stand for and
will be able to help you make the right
decisions
from now on you will work to ensure
everything you do is a good fit
if you do too many things that aren't a
good fit you'll feel uncomfortable
and people will feel that you're being
inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with
why your ability to stand out
find support and work to all your
natural
strengths will flourish with practice
you will learn to trust your why
you will eventually start to see your
job and the things you do as ways to
breathe life into your cause
and the better you get at it the more
you will feel that your life and
everything you do
has purpose the best way to implement
your why
is to work at it slowly you don't have
to do all the tips we
suggest what is important is that you
pick up to three
and commit to practicing and using them
now
imagine we're standing in a big empty
room
right and we're standing in one corner
and i give you a simple instruction
i want you to go to that corner in a
straight line
right off you go no big deal right
without telling you
i slip a chair in front of you what do
you do
you go around the chair now you just
disobeyed what i told you to do i told
you to go to that corner straight line
but this is the amazing things about
human beings which is when we're given a
clear destination
we use our own creativity and our own
sense of innovation and our own
problem-solving abilities
to overcome obstacles to get to the
destination in other words the
destination is more important than the
route
right we are flexible about the route we
are obsessed with the destination
reset we're standing in the corner
together and i give you a simple
instruction
go somewhere in this room in a straight
line and you say to me where do you want
me to go i'm like i don't know
you're smart figure it out go in a
straight line and so you pick a point
and you start walking
and without telling you i put a chair in
front of you and what do you do you come
to a grinding halt
and i say what did you stop for you go
will you put a chair in front of me
or you'll make a sudden turn and go in
another direction
right and this is the problem it's the
same obstacle
the difference is when you have a clear
set at a clear destination the obstacles
become
easy to overcome when you don't have a
clear destination you keep coming to a
grinding hold and what we do in our
companies
is we're counting the steps we're taking
along the route but we're never looking
at the destination
right so company says made a million
dollars this year we were only planning
on making eight hundred thousand we took
ten steps we're only planning on taking
eight
where are you going no clue right
we count the steps and so the point is
is that people want to feel that the
effort that they're exerting
actually are moving somewhere and so
successful measurement successful
recognition is not just for the steps
you take
it's not just for the effort it's that
the effort you exerted moved us
closer to where we're trying to get to
and that get to should be some crazy
ideal
my ideal is to live in a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single morning
you know inspired to go to work and
fulfilled by the work that they do and
the
the couple of measurements that i use
are if the book is selling and i by the
way people ask me how many have you sold
i have no clue
i've never asked the publisher because i
don't care i really don't care how many
i've sold
what i care about is the amazon rankings
and that those are going
steady or up and not plummeting because
that means other people
right because i don't have a publicist i
don't have a marketing strategy on
purpose i didn't hire one of those
companies
to sell the book for me and the reason
is is because i'm not interested in book
sales
i'm interested in spreading of an idea
and so i just use that as a metric to
help me understand
am i sort of marching in the because the
more i preach
is it resonating you know and so you
have a couple of these
imperfect measurements that help you
understand are you going along the way
so it's not just great effort look what
you achieved
because that's what we're doing now
right our goal is to increase top line
revenues by 50 million dollars
for what reason right which is we have
to know the destination
and then we say amazing
you took us that much closer and if we
go to the right it's because we were
overcoming an obstacle
if we hadn't gone to the right we would
have been stuck forever
thank you you know it's not always
straight lines
it's not always straight lines but it's
it's in one direction she's pulling the
cane out
how would someone know if they're doing
something for their why how do you know
oh you can feel it you feel it you ever
had that experience
where um you feel like something's wrong
you know sort of like you make a
decision but it makes you uncomfortable
you're not you're not following through
with your cause or your purpose and you
ever have a decision where everybody's
like you're crazy you're crazy like this
just feels like the most natural normal
thing
i could do i'm not even in doubt here
you know right now the problem with
simply running on gut is it's not
scalable this is the reason we want to
learn our why
learn to articulate and be able to speak
our why so that others
can understand why we're making the
decisions we're making
because the problem is if you only trust
your gut to those around you sometimes
it does appear that we're crazy or
unfocused
and so people leave us and don't help us
because they think we're nuts
the minute we can articulate and speak
that why with clarity that others can
understand
then not only will they have context for
the decisions we're making
but they'll rally to help us and even do
things that we didn't even ask because
they understand
the higher purpose that we're trying to
advance so
you just know it's a terrible answer um
but you can feel it and
this is where joy and fulfillment in our
work come from which is different from
happiness
you can win a big client get a promotion
get a raise happy
you know do a good job produce something
great happy
but that feeling dissipates it doesn't
last for
you know certainly doesn't last for
months or years it might last for days
or weeks
right that that immensely happy feeling
that we all have that big client we won
or that big promotion we got is now gone
joy fulfillment which doesn't mean that
we love every day but joy and
fulfillment
comes from that feeling that every day
our work is contributing to something
bigger
and that's that's way more important
also at least as important
in the 18th century
there was something that spread across
europe and eventually made its way to
america called
puerto fever also known as the black
death of child bed basically what was
happening
is women were giving birth and
they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of europe
and it got worse and worse and worse
over the course
of over a century in some hospitals
it was as high as 70 percent of women
who gave birth
who would die as a result of giving
birth but this was the renaissance
this was the time of empirical data and
science
and we had thrown away things like
tradition and mysticism
these were men of science these were
doctors and these doctors and men of
science
wanted to study and try and find the
reason
for this black death of child bed and so
they got to work
studying and they would study the
corpses
of the of the women who had died and in
the morning they would conduct autopsies
and then in the afternoon they would go
and deliver babies and finish their
rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s
that dr oliver wendell holmes father of
supreme court justice
oliver wendell holmes realized that all
of these doctors were conducting
autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands before they
delivered babies
in the afternoon and he pointed it out
and said guys you're the problem
and they ignored him and called him
crazy
for 30 years until
finally somebody realized that if they
simply washed their hands
it would go away and that's exactly what
happened
when they started sterilizing their
instruments and washing their hands
the black death of childbed disappeared
my point is the lesson here is sometimes
you're the problem
we've seen this happen all too recently
with our new men of science and
empirical
uh studiers and these men of
finance who are smarter than the rest of
us until the thing collapsed
and they blamed everything else except
themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your actions
you can take all the credit in the world
for the things that you do right
as long as you also take responsibility
for the things you do wrong it must be a
balanced equation
you don't get it one way and not the
other you get to take credit
when you also take accountability if you
want to change your life
in the next 30 days for free check out
my training right here below or if you
want some more affirmations from rob and
sharma check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there